[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for security
policy
it happened on world hijab day a Muslim
student at the University of Central
Florida
Ryan souk area grew enraged when she
invited another student Cathy Jew to Don
a hijab in solidarity with supposedly
oppressed Muslim women and she refused
Sakarya took to Twitter and admonished
her you didn't even take the time to ask
questions or try to understand what his
jab is that's ignorant of you you
literally sprinted after taking the
photos pathetic more ominously souk Aria
added Twitter do your thing let's get
this girl expelled ignorance will not be
tolerated at my campus happily UCF
officials rejected this call to expel
Cathy's Jew but that souq aria made it
at all let slip the authoritarianism and
coercion that is at the heart of both
leftism and islam sook arias call
reveals the problem that many in the
West have with the hid jab in the first
place that it is not a free choice for
all too many Muslim women but a symbol
of their oppression and subjugation
indeed world hijab day is a sick farce
in the first place Muslim women all over
the world are forced to wear the hijab
and subjected to violence if they do not
courageous women in the Islamic Republic
of Iran are now taking off their hijabs
as a sign of their resistance to the
oppressive Sharia regime under which
they live and at least 29 women have so
far been arrested for doing so yet
instead of recognizing these things
women in the US are fed the false
narrative that had jab wearing women are
harassed and persecuted in the West and
that they must stand in solidarity with
them that harassment and persecution are
far more manufactured than real just
weeks ago an 11 year old girl in Toronto
made international headlines with her
claim that a man had followed her and
cut her hijab with scissors after an
investigation police concluded that the
attack never happened
likewise Yasmin suede a Muslim teen who
claimed into
number 2016 that Trump supporters on a
New York subway tour off her hijab while
no one in the packed subway car did a
thing to help her she too gained
international media attention and she
too made up the whole thing shortly
before that a hijab wearing Muslim
student at San Diego State University
also falsely claimed that she was
assaulted by Trump supporters there are
many such incidents in July 2017 a
muslima in Britain also falsely claimed
that a man had pulled off her hijab in a
race hate attack in November 2016 and
the university of michigan muslim
student claims that she was accosted by
a white man who told her to remove her
hijab or he would set her ablaze with a
cigarette lighter
she also fabricated the whole event
nonetheless on world had jabbed a
non-muslim women all over the country
put on his abs in solidarity with Muslim
women who were supposedly plagued by
Islamophobic harassment but where is
their concern for Aqsa Parvez whose
Muslim father choked her to death with
her hijab after she refused to wear it
or Amina museli
a Christian woman in Somalia whom
Muslims murdered because she wasn't
wearing a hijab or the 40 women in who
were murdered in Iraq in 2007 for not
wearing the hijab or alia a safar whose
muslim cousin threatened to kill her and
harm her family because she stopped
wearing the hijab in Britain or Amira
Osman Hameed who faced whipping in Sudan
for refusing to wear the hijab or the
Egyptian girl also named Amira who
committed suicide after being brutalized
for her family for refusing to wear the
hijab or the Muslim and non-muslim
teachers at the Islamic College of South
Australia who were told that they had to
wear the hijab or be fired or the women
in Chechnya whom police shot with
paintballs because they weren't wearing
hijab or the women also in Chechnya who
were threatened by men with automatic
rifles for not wearing hijab or the
elementary school teachers in Tunisia
who were threatened with death for not
wearing hijab or the Syrian schoolgirls
who were forbidden to go to school
unless they wore hijab or the women in
Gaza whom Hamas has forced to wear hijab
or the women in Iran who protested
against the regime
even before the recent uprising by
daring to take off their hijabs or the
women in London who Muslim thugs
threatened to murder if they didn't wear
hijab or the anonymous young Muslim
woman who doctor had jab outside her
home and started living a double life in
fear of her parents were the 15 girls in
Saudi Arabia who were killed when the
religious police wouldn't let them leave
their burning school building because
they had taken off their hid jabs in
their all-female environment or the girl
in Italy whose mother shaved her head
for not wearing a jab or all the other
women and girls who have been killed or
threatened or who live in fear for
daring not to wear the Haddad who is
standing in solidarity with them not
Western feminists meanwhile at the
University of Central Florida
Kathy Zhu noted I think it's kind of
ridiculous how people are trying to
censor others for disagreeing with them
and then trying to get them kicked out
that's the definition of fascism indeed
and that's campus life in the United
States 2018 I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]